[Musique]
et bien je veux que tu comprennes à quel
point ta mère était une femme bien
elle a pris golden Briggs le pire tueur
que j'ai jamais rencontré et elle l'a
transformé en paire de famille
ma maman est morte maintenant
j'entrerai d'une manière ou d'une autre
donne-moi les noms des hommes qui ont
fait ça donc cette petite fille est en
vie il n'y a pas de place pour la
vengeance
protège un tueur d'un autre tueur
tu pourras m'apprendre à tirer
mettez tous les deux vos mains derrière
le dos allez crois-moi ce fusil
mon père veut votre fils je vais faire
sauter la cervelle de cette petite fille
sans le moindre état d'âme tu n'as peur
de rien
lui qui toute ma vie j'avais vu la peur
dans les yeux de tous les hommes que
j'avais rencontré s'il vous plaît ne
plus tard
faisons-le à l'ancienne mon père sera
toujours un homme
bien
les gars vous avez réveillé le diable
[Musique]